If we don't heed the lessons of the
1970s,
which were bad lessons and the lessons
be early part of this decade,
um,
then,
uh,
we will find ourselves in trouble.
Um,
and that is no matter what happens
during a period like this,
it is critical to preserve the quality
of life.
The schools have to continue to improve.
Crime cannot go up,
and ideally it has to go down.
The parks have to remain clean and well
maintained.
Our cultural institutions need to be
supported.
Housing stock has to be maintained and
people have to be able to afford to live
here where you maintain the quality of
life.
Yes,
we will all suffer somewhat during a
period of like this.
I think the mayor is the single best
person in the world to manage through a
crisis like this because he's very good
at finding ways of doing more with less
and understands fundamentally that what
this all is about is maintaining and
enhancing that quality of life so that
when the recovery does occur,
we haven't set ourselves back so far.
They will spend decades trying to dig
ourselves out of the hole.